et encore je n'ai jamais fouillé ou
contrôler l'identité d'un journaliste
quand vous êtes je vais vous prendre un
exemple assez des scripts de comprendre
vous allez mieux comprendre la fonction
quand on était en guyane il ya des gens
qui ont attaqué la préfecture je réponds
à la question madame d'un contrat s'il
vous plaît juste je réponds à la
question vous avez l'autorité
administrative le secrétaire général de
la préfecture en l'occurrence qui est à
côté de vous et vous avez 500 personnes
qui attaquent les gendarmes qui
attaquent les policiers qui attaquent la
préfecture il se tourne vers vous et ils
vous demandent qu'est-ce qu'on fait je
sais que ce que je dis est pas
politiquement correct mais c'est la
réalité
l'autorité administrative ne prendra
aucune décision sans l'aval de
l'autorité politique et donc vous
représentez le cabinet du président de
la république donc si à un moment où
vous demande est ce que je dois prendre
tels moyens ou si vous devez orienter la
manière dont vous voyez les choses
eh ben vous le faites et quand vous avez
des gens qui atteignent à la vie privée
du président de la république qui le
harcèle sur son lieu de vacances
vous prenez en responsabilité des
décisions qui sont celles de dire aux
policiers du j'espère qu'ils ne savent
pas s'ils doivent le faire ou pas le
faire quand la personne a franchi les
limites est rentré sur une propriété
privée pour photographier
madame ou monsieur en maillot de bain et
ben vous expliquer aux policiers il n'a
pas le faire mais quand on fait du
politiquement correct on dit non mais
j'ai pas donné l'ordre d'aller
interpeller
il a commis un délit il a été contrôlé
par les policiers il a été placé en
garde à vue par un commissaire de police
sa part alexandre reynal cebenna rang va
s'en tenir là pour cette réponse
j'attire l'attention des collègues que
si monsieur benalla avait possédé
lui-même à des contrôles d'identité ou à
des fouilles se serait défait
potentiellement délictueux tout à fait
qu'il n'appartient pas à notre
commission dans lequel parlementaire de
l'amener à s'exprimer sur des délits
qu'ils auraient éventuellement commis ce
qui n'est pas le cas sur les noms